In France, 250,000 union members took to the streets of Paris...
...to protest President Emmanuel Macron's planned pension overhaul.
Ukraine opens a criminal investigation...
...into President Donald Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,...
...after released text messages between them indicate Giuliani and his associates...
...surveilled then US Ambassador to Ukraine Marie Yovanovitch.
In Russia, lawmakers approved President Vladimir Putin's choice for a new prime minister,...
...a day after Putin announced constitutional reforms...
...and the resignation of the government.
In Japan, the government said a man treated for pneumonia after returning from China...
...has tested positive for the new coronavirus...
...identified as a possible cause of an outbreak...
...that has sickened dozens in the Chinese city of Wuhan.
Finally from Spain, a former bank chairman was fined 58 million dollars...
...for smuggling a Picasso painting, a designated national treasure, out of the country.